This is more perfect. I'm Jad Abumrad this week conversation about a mystery.
It's a mystery actually that's connected to one of my favorite stories we've
done so far. The political thicket,
the political thicken of the court must not enter the political thicket.
And the imagery at the thicket is that, uh, you know,
the deer very proudly with his new horns goes into the thicket,
gets entangled and can never get out.
Frank for years, claim was once the courts are in,
there will be nothing beyond it and someday the courts will be forced to declare
winners and losers. A very high profile elections.
If you haven't heard this story, definitely hit pause right now.
Go back in the feed, find the story called political thicket.
Listen to it is definitely one of my favorites. It's essentially a,
the story of a case that many people point to as being the first time that the
supreme court got into politics or soiled themselves with politics,
which you can make a beeline from that moment to Bush v Gore,
that case 1962. It was so traumatic for,
uh, the court that to,
it literally broke two justices like shattered two human beings and one of those
two justices.
Justice Felix Frankfurter is at the center of the mystery we're about to tell
you about. But just to give you a sense of who he was,
I'm gonna play you a little clip from that earlier story. Um,
he was extremely smart, towering figure, but as a person,
just as friend, just as frankfurter,
he wasn't necessarily the nicest person. I heard that from everyone I talk to.
I always call him a Bantam Rooster.
He was a difficult crusty figure who was short.
A little bit of a pouch on him was one of the most condescending egotistical of
justices. So Justice Felix Frankfurter,
I'm not the nicest guy, but important,
presided over a ton of really important cases. Like for example,
Brown v Board of Education,
big one where we began the slow march towards desegregating our school system.
Anyhow, the mystery today deals with his papers.
These are the notes that he took while he was on the bench. You know,
drafts of decisions that he wrote Descente road, a memos,
backs and forth with the other justices.
Maybe the notes he took when they were all in that secret conference room that
they go to when they're arguing.
It's kind of stuff that like people like us are like, aw man,
we gotta get those papers. But this case
there are no papers.
Which brings us to this story of one of the biggest heist in supreme court
history,
the vanishing of Justice Felix Frankfurter's papers from the library of
Congress. One day they were there and then poof, God.
And ever since people have been like, where, what, where, where are they?
What happened? Who took them? Harvard historian and New Yorker Staff Writer,
Sheila Por who you may remember, Oh,
was a big part of our guns episode we just released.
She recently tried to get to the bottom of this paper Kapor and more perfect
producer Sean Ramas from talk to her about it
in such an ecosystem where it's so hard to gain access to these papers,
to these documents.
At some point someone might try to gain access to them unlawfully,
which you once wrote a wonderful story about that.
I was hoping you could maybe retail and I,
I was thinking here we are telling stories so maybe just,
yeah, so imagine we're sitting by the fire. Yeah,
you can hear it kind of crackle and there is a,
the evenings crickets field.
There it is. There it is.
So the largest heist in the history of the library of Congress,
I guarantee you would not have guessed because I have not have guessed that it
was a paper to Felix Frankfurter.
More than a thousand pages of Frankfurt papers were stolen from the library of
Congress and that early 1970s they have never been recovered.
Not a single page of them.
It was a kind of extraordinary heist that was investigated by the FBI.
They had a prime suspect. They can, you know, have,
there was a grand jury called this extensive investigation involved the nation's
leading journalists involved other members of the court,
the nation's leading legal scholars were questioned and were part of the
investigation. The whole thing unraveled days,
hours before the Saturday night massacre and the sort of explosion of Watergate
and was quickly forgotten.
Hmm. Does all of this, this immense personality, this historic figure,
does this play into why it was his papers that were stolen or were they just the
ones that were in the library at the right time for someone to steal?
Yeah, I don't think we know that I,
unless the mystery really solved and I felt like I got so close.
What? What didn't you have to put it all together? Can you reveal that?
I guess when you think about it, we're trying to solve a theft.
You need to know the motive of the thief and to know the motive of the thief,
you need to know what was stolen. But in Frankfurter's case,
his papers had only really just got to the library of Congress,
so when the papers disappeared for a long time,
nobody even noticed it because they hadn't really processed and they shouldn't
probably have been letting people look at them because it's then you can,
it's hard to reconstruct what's missing. What's clear from what was missing.
Of these more than a thousand pages is that it was the best stuff.
And so one theory that the FBI early on was some was trying to make money cause
you could like all of it frankfurters corresponds with Lyndon Johnson for
instance, was missing and we were like, all right, this presidential signature,
you could sell that. I mean,
where are you going to sell these things is another question.
But like maybe that's what was the case,
the next theory that the library working with the FBI had was, okay,
so it's a scholar
and a scholar who just, who wants to have it,
like wants to have this stuff and doesn't want anybody else to have it.
Like a collector or something like, oh yeah, like go just, you know,
sometimes when you, um,
when you're working on a project just for like a journalist,
you don't want to be scooped scholars of the same thing.
Maybe finds out something incredibly juicy.
Like imagine that someone's reading Frankfurter's diary and finds out,
Okay Frankfurter [inaudible] I slept with William Douglas,
his wife or something. I don't know what it would be like.
There's some big afraid for fixing finger.
He's gonna like rule against him forever.
And you know like just something that you need to be like,
I'm going to write a biography of Frankfurter and this is how I'm going to sell
it. Right. So the last thing you would want would be for another scholar go,
I've had this, I have find things in the archives all the time. Shoot,
they put it back in the box and you give it back to the librarian and you know
it's, someone else is going to call her on, never going to get this out in time.
And you just kind of forget about it. Cause as you can imagine,
it's just too cool. Someone else going to find it.
So maybe someone like that like that you could imagine a journalist just aren't
you? We can imagine this person, right? Sure. And they would just can't resist.
And there was no security in the library of Congress at the time. But I taught,
I interviewed everybody who was investigated by the FBI and they,
these hilarious stories, they're like, yeah, well they had a photocopy,
they're like a xerox machine, like an early xerox machine,
and you like put a nickel in it, but they would just let you take folders down.
It was like down the hall and up a set of stairs and through a double doors and
go through the bathroom and out the back door of the bathroom.
And there was this one xerox machine,
you can put a nickel in and you just walk out the door with your folders and
like, you can't do that anymore. Not Elaborate. Congas really not anywhere.
And it was this case that actually led to a crackdown.
So the FBI quickly came to the conclusion that whoever had bothered to do the
incredible labor of steel and all those papers,
because a lot of smuggling would've been someone who both really wanted to write
about.
Frankfurter had found something incredibly juicy but had been thwarted by the
kind of cabal of Frankfurt or people, which was,
these people are called the hot dogs where the
best thing we're sitting by the campfire now is when the hot dogs go on the,
like we've been sharpening our wooden sticks, our green wooden sticks.
Now you put on the hugs and roast them.
The hot dogs are the former clerks of Frankfurt.
They were known as the hot dogs and loved him because like many an ordinary
person, you know, apparently it was just a very stand up person to work with Hm.
When you're on the inside. And they were con, you know,
kind of protecting his legacy. Anyway,
so the case just kind of just get steamrolled by Watergate.
But this is kind of like the Alex Jones theory of the Felix frame.
It's not that it is not the, no, it's not stupid fairness.
Cause actually there are two incredibly, uh, diligent legal scholars, peace,
peace, this element of this story together. Um, and I, uh, it's,
it's a little conspiracy theory minded, but it's not beyond the pale.
So one of the pieces of paper that appears to have been missing from
Frankfurter's papers
is really interesting and was potentially quite damaging to William Rehnquist,
who had been nominated to serve on the court and whose
confirmation proceedings were happening right at the time that Frankfurter's
papers were ransacked.
What was controversial for Rehnquist was the issue that had thwarted Nixon's
earlier judicial appointments,
which was his relationship to segregation. Nixon, who you will recall,
was pursuing a southern strategy trying to a white southern Democrats had
nominated some potential justices who were segregationists or certainly had been
segregationists earlier in their career. In any case, Rehnquist was not,
but rank was served as a clerk for Robert Jackson in 1950s and asked by Jackson
to prepare a memo about Brown v Board.
Rankest had written a memo in which he wrote,
I realize it is an unpopular and on humanitarian position for which I have been
excoriated by liberal colleagues,
but I think Plessy v Ferguson was right and should be reaffirmed.
Plessy v Ferguson, the 1896 decision, uh,
instituted the legal principle of separate but equal the establish the system of
Jim Crow, legalize a system of Jim Crow. And so it's published, you know,
in Newsweek and then it'd be becomes explosive.
And a real big problem for rank was during his confirmation
rank was worked very hard to quiet that storm. He said,
I wasn't expressing my own views.
I was asked to write a memo about Justice Jackson's views
and Jackson's secretary, former Secretary Elsie Douglas,
she told reporters that's just a lie.
Like Jacqueline didn't ask his clerks to write down memos about what Jackson
should think. Jackson knew what he thought.
He asked his clerks to tell him what they thought so he could elaborate,
you know,
that he could kind of deliberate on the multiple positions that they would
present him with. So rank was, sends a letter to the Senate Judiciary Committee,
tried to explain all of this.
And Senate Judiciary Committee threatens to hold hearings over the holiday or
after Christmas. This is December of 1971. Uh,
Nixon starts putting pressure on, on senators.
And you can imagine somebody at this point might've thought, I wonder,
well if there's anything in frankfurters papers,
which are huge ones you've just been given to the, you know,
recently given to the library of Congress that would cast light on the Rehnquist
nomination.
And one of the things that is no longer in frankfurters papers but appears to
have been both from before the law,
the theft is a letter that Rehnquist wrote to Frankfurter in 1955 on the
question of segregation. The memo to Jackson was from 1952.
Uh, and there are these two legal scholars,
Brad Snyder and John Barrett who argue that bankwest would have revisited the
arguments that he made in 1952 in that letter to frankfurter and it someone from
the FBI or from the Nixon White House or one of the White House plumbers or any
of these nefarious people could have been told by Nixon, by Haldeman,
by you know, any of these jokes. Christian the way Nixon White House,
get yourself together as down love of Congress and pull anything from Rehnquist,
from frankfurters papers. But to hide your tracks.
Just take a bunch of that crap out. You know, we didn't want,
we want to make it,
we want to make look like someone actually stole Frankfurter's papers.
Like as if anybody came. You know what I mean? Like that.
It was the whole thing was yet another Watergate coverup, you know,
yet another not a dirty trick, which is kind of a cool theory isn't it?
It's great. It's great.
Is that conspiracy theory also to you in your eyes the most credible or do you,
do you have an alternate theory of who may have taken them?
Do you think it could have been just some nebbish academic or or biographer?
I do have a theory, a fair amount of evidence for that theory. Okay.
I can't tell you that theory.
Ah,
and in that theory we are disappointed to learn that it is very unlikely that
the papers still exist.
The FBI had a prime suspect who denied any involvement and did not accept an
offer for kind of amnesty in exchange for returning the papers.
So although you know,
they tended to believe that that person probably had the papers.
The FBI never made an arrest. The FBI absolutely never made an arrest,
and they talked to a lot of people. They did.
They did take the investigation really seriously. But on the other hand,
if the FBI had conducted the heist in the first place,
wouldn't their investigation had been just designed to cover up? Sure.
But they were the culprits who would have to be thorough. Yeah, right. I mean,
they're not going to be like, oh,
the library of Congress calls and Frankfurter's papers are missing.
It'd be like, Hey, we're too busy. Because that would look that,
that would look very suspicious if they'd taken them. I love that theory.
I didn't think fun theory. That explains a lot. It's great, but,
but there's very little evidence. I'm just going to be completely clear.
There's almost no evidence where, what's her?
It's just that the timeline works out. It's a little but like, hmm.
You know how the New York Times published that timeline of the kind of, Oh,
this is the day that Donald Trump jr met with Natalia and this is the day that
wikileaks published that you know the timeline lines up beautifully,
but that is not enough.
[inaudible]
coming up. We'll take a step back and ask, how in the world did this happen?
Could this happen? Like who gets to decide what happens to these courts
papers, this bit of history that's coming up.
He's from Washington, from snap, snap, duck live walks,
Nashville's Wyman theater in March 16th and I'm bringing the best cars in the
world. Pride laughs, a more amazing night out. And yes,
she's coming. The funniest woman in the world. Jen Kober
[inaudible] in the lady forest. Jen POBA rocks a brand new story.
Get tickets. It's snap judgement. That'll org.
I've never gotten applause for it before. If you guys
call my mom, that'd be awesome. She's still pissed.
This is more perfect.
I'm Jad Abumrad back to our conversation with more perfect producers.
Sean rums from and Harvard Historian and New Yorker Staff Writer, Gillette Por.
So,
so what's the supreme court's official policy and all the papers that go through
the Supreme Court? What do they do with all that?
The Supreme Court's official policy as it is none of your business.
It's very surprised myself was frankly surprised to discover this,
that the national records act,
presidential records act legislation that protects the other papers of the
federal government specifically excludes the Supreme Court.
So what happens is completely up to the justices, including most importantly,
the discussions that the judges have in conference and their notes from those
discussions and the papers that their clerks assemble for them and preparing how
to consider a case or preparing for a case that they decide not to consider.
It's completely the discretion of the justice,
whether to preserve that for the future for historians, for the public,
for that matter, for journalists, they could destroy it all and they often do.
And how far back to this date? Eight goes back to John Marshall,
who's one of the most important chief justices.
Marshall was an incredibly effective leader of the court, but he,
under his tenure, the court gained an enormous amount of stature.
But he really believed that for the justices to be able to confer with full
candor,
their deliberations needed to be secret in perpetuity.
A lot of people at the time opposed at Jefferson in particular,
that it was completely inexcusable.
That of really important value in a republic is transparency.
And Marshall was essentially making a power grab [inaudible] he loved the idea
of the mystery of the court and the mystique of the courtroom. He was a great,
he's a great of power. So, um,
the tradition dates from Marshall and they were very strong arguments to be made
in favor of the deliberations being kept secret,
I think certainly for a period of time,
but that we should never know what was behind these decisions,
whose I think from the vantage of a historian, ah,
that's not okay. Um, but from the, the political principle I,
that there are strong debates on the other side,
there's a strong argument to be made that there is, that it is indefensible.
First of all, they can decide to save nothing. They can burn their papers,
has no small number of them, have indeed done second,
they can decide they're gonna give their papers to an archive,
then they can give it to a really inconvenient archive. Um,
let's say there's a rule and there's nine justices.
You want to read each of their conference notes and see the pain,
the folders that they assembled, the papers about the case.
He could very well have to go to many, far from places, which that is,
doesn't seem maybe that inconvenient maybe to your listeners,
but it's hard work being storying and getting enough money to even get to these
places hard. Uh,
but these are people whose career has been spent paid by taxpayer funds to do
the work of the federal government. And these,
the portion of their papers that concerns the work they did for the federal
government. A lot of people might say prolongs to the public.
My own view is it is indefensible that the court has no policy with regard to
court related papers of it's justices. They're rules people.
These people can't set a rule for themselves in the,
but I understand they don't want congress sitting a rule about it, that,
that for them that falls under a separation of powers issue.
But they should have the rule and the rule just shouldn't be.
You can have your kids decide to burn all of your papers when you die.
What do you think it would take for such a rule at this point to be past?
I would have thought, honestly,
that it might've come in the aftermath of the Bush v Gore decision in 2000 when
people might've said, do you know what? Supreme Court is really powerful.
And in an era of judicial supremacy,
we actually need the supreme court to be saving his papers because future
generations need to understand by what means did those nine people come to that
decision?
Um,
if you could steal the papers of any Supreme Court justice living or dead or
just, you know, borrow for a weekend to pour over, who's would you steal?
Oh my gosh, that's a good question.
I'm going to just go for the gold here. [inaudible] John Marshall Classic.
Yeah. Just the kind of original guy. He was Jefferson's cousin.
He started on the bench with Bushrod, Washington, George Washington's cousin.
These guys were making momentous decisions early on, you know Madison Beam,
the Marbury. What did he rank people into that? Huh? Who Cares about me?
Isn't that I don't really want it. Was he like,
was he sleeping with the boarding house sown and you chose you to be the guy who
like invented the Supreme Court? That's a good choice. That's a good choice.
I'm prepared to defend it. Second choice feelings
more. Perfect. Sean Ramez from speaking with historian Jill Lapoure,
if you want to learn more about this,
definitely check out an article that she wrote in The New Yorker called the
great paper Caper. By the way,
a Bushrod Washington was George Washington's nephew, not cousin, but whatever.
Supreme Court audio in this show. It's from OEA,
a free law project in collaboration with the legal information institute at
Cornell.
Leadership support for more perfect is provided by the Joyce Foundation.
Additional funding is provided by the Charles Evans Hughes Memorial Foundation.
I'm Jad Abumrad more perfect. We'll be back in just a few days.